if I see this right and the Sun is like
s equal loose and this is P what do you
think P stands for it's it's a product
right you're you're multiplying things
together rather than adding them
together so this B metaphor is exactly
the same format as this is equal to not
13 plus but 13 times
is it like factorial kind of yeah so
it's very easy to write factorial
notation using this not that you'd have
to but forces how do I write something
like a like six factorial I would say
okay firstly it's a product right where
would you like to start
okay equals 1/8 let's let's go ahh now
be careful right built into both Sigma
and PI there's it's terrible crickets
and for everything but anyway
segmentation and that notation right is
that you start from here and you go up
to here oh okay okay now we'll get to
what happens if feeling what if I don't
want to what if it was started for and
ever to believe me we'll get there okay
but for now rather than get your wires
crossed we start another and we
increment up to get to the next one okay
or to get to the last one right yeah
thank people is there any point to it
what what it does help me way to tell is
if I what six times then I could know I
was going to start one and it seeks
right rather than like think of some
arbitrary thing where it's like I don't
know where I'm going to end I might as
well have a first term big that one term
okay now careful with this right because
you know six factorial is equal to raise
six by five by four by three by three by
one okay I can count now I could write
this in reverse order I could write but
let's try writing in the right order
right let's try and write it so that it
will come out like this rather than this
even though this will probably be easier
right if I wanted to go down I was just
going to work
negative so let's think about this let's
think about this right just like just
like in this case and iam in this case
right these numbers form an AP right
form an AP 6 5 4 3 2 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 or so
forms an AP but 2 different if he's
right because did we not establish last
week that order really freaking matters
right okay so it's the same numbers but
all is different what's the common
difference for the 1 2 3 4 5 6
it's plus 1 isn't it what's the kind of
difference for the one we want is minus
1 okay so therefore come on is other
wheels turning yet
if this makes you increment up by 7
every time and this makes me into
increment up by 2 every time I want to
increment up by a negative number does
it work does it work it's okay I forgive
you it's a dummy variable so it doesn't
matter anyway now you're gonna have some
trouble if this and this don't with my
left um yeah will it work
k equals 1 hey we'll give me 7 minus 1
which is 6 and then K goes to give me 7
minus 2 which is 5 I'm not here what